it's beautiful out there wow look at
that sun coming up with just a few thin
cirrus clouds out there to cover it up
for now but that won't last for long so
we still have a lot of moisture in the
air from yesterday's rainfall we're at
79 percent humidity and 36 is the dew
point which measures the moisture in the
air so there's a lot of moisture in
comparison to the temperature which is
42. that's going to stick around for
today and then slowly we're going to dry
out as we have sunny
days over the next well really right
through the weekend 24 hour change we're
about five degrees cooler than we were
yesterday sunrise at 6 49 in the sunset
at 4 54. so the days are slowly getting
longer nights are getting just a little
bit shorter just a little bit we've got
some chilly 20's up in indian springs
mid 30's for perhaps upper 30's for
mosquito 37 boulder city at 43 just
under 50 degrees in laughlin this
morning laughlin and all along the
colorado river valley will get some
pretty gusty north winds tomorrow
and then the valley will feel some
breezes but then we're going to get some
stronger winds into friday and saturday
and i'll show you where that wind is
coming from today 63 degrees
the normal high is 59. boy the record
low 10
back in 1943 on this date now that's a
cold morning 74 is the record so we'll
just be a little bit above normal and
that's thanks to high pressure that's
going to rebuild now out of from the
eastern pacific and over the desert
southwest so that's going to keep the
storm track up north again and keep our
skies pretty clear so
these few little thin high clouds we've
got this morning will thin out we'll see
good sunshine today so there is a wind
advisory issued for lake mead lake
mojave and all along the colorado river
valley that's for thursday 4 a.m to 4
p.m as that first little system travels
through so up and over that ridge of
high pressure we'll get a few systems a
few little bursts of energy and that's
going to really create the north winds
for us 63 today don't worry about gusty
winds tomorrow will be breezy in the
valley but stronger winds along the
river and out at the lakes and then
friday a stronger system and it's not
bringing rain or clouds but it will
bring those north winds late friday
overnight into early saturday those are
going to be some stronger winds and
we'll feel those in the valley too and
in the outlying area so just put those
in your outdoor plans if you're making
plans right now